this shouldn't surprise you at this
point but heather josh and the other
stars of the blair witch films didn't
really die some launched careers in
hollywood while others have turned their
back on the business here's what
happened to the cast of the blair witch
movies
she's the most recognizable face of the
blair witch franchise and that's not
necessarily a good thing as heather
donahue sadly admitted to the guardian
in 2016 my name and face are forever
going to be someone else's intellectual
property this is what happened when she
shot to stardom playing herself as the
film's lead blair witch believer and
documentarian investigator while she
said that making the film was a joy
immediate success afterwards was elusive
especially as the marketing team at
artisan entertainment wanted her to act
as though she were really dead for a
long time her imdb profile listed her as
deceased at age 24. this confusion about
her mortality status didn't help land
her many subsequent roles but she did
manage to carve out parts in a dozen or
so movies later before calling it quits
on hollywood in 2007. her next move was
to the sierra nevada foothills where she
became a grower of medical marijuana
donahue's high times became the basis
for her green memoir grow girl which was
published in 2012. she then co-created
and tried to shop around a pot comedy
pilot called the high country these days
donahue is currently focused on
developing a line of herbal skincare
products and inspiring and teaching
others to share their own stories
through writing
josh leonard told the guardian back in
2018 i was up for any kind of adventure
back then so said yes when directors
daniel myrick and eduardo sanchez asked
me to play the cameraman leonard also
experienced troubles being listed as
deceased on imdb by the artisan
marketing department to the point that
his parents started getting condolence
calls in response to the fake news his
career came very much alive after the
film and he decided to earnestly pursue
the craft of acting and stop quote being
the guy from blair witch a year later he
appeared opposite robert de niro and
cuba gooding jr in men of honor followed
by a steady diet of independent films
network tv shows and video game
voiceovers
inspired by his work in lynn shelton's
improvised 2009 mumblecore film hump day
he branched out as a director with
2011's the lie and later with 2018 stark
was the knight and 2020s fully realized
humans leonard continues to be a working
actor in projects like steven
soderbergh's 2018 iphone horror flick on
sane and tv series including bates motel
and togetherness he has been married to
fellow actor alison pill since 2015.
michael williams is a very common name
but the bronx-born sometimes actor knows
you know him better as mike aka the map
guy aka the guy in the corner from the
blair witch project he extended his
resume by guesting on a few tv shows
like law order and fbi as well as
reuniting with director eduardo sanchez
for his 2006 horror film altered
williams enlisted sanchez and his witch
co-star joshua leonard for the 2013 web
series four corners of fear while he
does have a few new projects on the
horizon williams has moved away from
having a full-time career as an actor he
currently works as a school counselor is
an adjunct faculty member at the jacob
burns media arts lab and runs the mcw
acting studio alongside his wife tony
williams is currently writing a book
about his debut film with the working
title escaping the most famous corner in
hollywood how he survived the blair
witch in his free time he enjoys fishing
in the great outdoors
ed swanson isn't much of a fisherman nor
an actor but he played up both in the
blair witch project as our trio of
filmmakers headed deep into the woods
swanson was on director eduardo
sanchez's softball team and was asked to
play a part in the movie besides that
performance swanson hasn't acted outside
of community and church theater he was
in the marine corps and got out right
before the gulf war this brought him to
maryland where the film was shot and he
still resides there to this day now in
his 50s he's carved out a niche for
himself as an artisan who creates clocks
as for his fishing buddy with the hat in
the film bob griffin he had never met
him before the film nor saw him after
according to swanson his scene partner
has since passed away
susie gooch was in the right place at
the right time when she and her young
daughter ingrid were interviewed for
what they thought was an actual student
film they didn't think much about their
ad-lib lines until a friend two years
later said they'd seen them in a movie
called the blair witch project where
susie was listed in the credits as
jackie hallx the non-acting natural
ladies relished their roles in the film
and have happily appeared at screenings
and filming location tours in the years
since susie has been a teacher for over
34 years and currently works as a tutor
in maryland ingrid graduated from hood
college with a master's of science in
clinical mental health counseling is
currently the lead clinician at an
outpatient recovery center is a big corn
fan and is engaged to be married
attempting to capitalize on the hoopla
behind the blair witch project a
quasi-sequel book of shadows blair witch
2 hit theaters a year later launching a
filming location's tour of the first
film within this film led by jeffrey
patterson patterson was played by
jeffrey donovan who knew the risks of
alienating fans of the original by
outright saying it was pure fiction fans
and critics didn't care for this
approach but it had little effect on
donovan's career his acting visibility
started to pick up steam when he
appeared in the 2005 will smith vehicle
hitch and two years later he landed a
stint on tv's crossing jordan leading
man's status was achieved when he got
noticed as michael weston in usa
network's burn notice in between he
played robert f kennedy and clint
eastwood's j edgar and later his brother
john f and rob reiner's lbj other works
of notes include season two of fargo
playing opposite angelina jolie in
eastwood's changeling and in lucy in the
sky alongside natalie portman
when kim director heard about a blair
witch sequel she was skeptical at first
but hit the floor when she found out she
was going to be directed by acclaimed
paradise lost documentarian joe
burlinger she described her psychic king
diamond character in book of shadows as
a very intuitive slightly depressed
acidic goth girl director feels the
follow-up didn't do well because of poor
marketing and that it ultimately had a
lot that it had to fight against i
thought the movie was cool despite its
failure book of shadows was a breakout
role for director actually her fourth
one after securing small parts in the
spike lee films he got game summer of
sam and bamboozled she reunited with lee
in 2004 where she hate me 2006 is inside
man and the netflix series version of
she's gotta have it outside of her
league collaborations she is kept busy
with other films as well as appearances
in notable shows like sex in the city
law and order oranges the new black the
good wife and gotham one of her larger
more memorable recent roles was as the
sex worker shea on hbo's the deuce
2016's blair witch was more of a true
sequel to the original than book of
shadows it finds heather's younger
brother james heading into those same
scary woods to try and find his sister
mccoon told digital trends there was a
lot of pressure to live up to the
standards of the first one the film
literally gave him nightmares and in
2016 he told usa today i had dreams of
being chased by a creature down an
alleyway on a regular basis i'd have
dreams of being ripped apart
mccoon is no stranger to nightmare as
having appeared in 11 episodes of the
walking dead as farmhand jimmy he's also
made appearances on series such as
shameless homeland and how to get away
with murder in films he's appeared
opposite the rock and snitch and had a
role in mary herron's tragic lifetime
movie anna nicole recently he has also
added the roles of producer and
assistant director to his profile having
worked on the web series sugarpine 7 and
the short film taipei jesus
lisa arlington wanted to make a
documentary called the absence of
closure including the story of heather
donahue's brother and her boyfriend
james and even launched a kickstarter to
help her make it a reality in actual
reality lisa arlington was played by
cali hernandez who had a weirdly fun
time working on the third witch film's
memorable dirty tunnel scene in an
interview with slash film she recalled
having a better time handling the close
quarters than the claustrophobic camera
guy did hernandez's acting career didn't
start until her early 20s but when it
did it started with a bang landing a
role that was later cut in terrence
malik's song to song that was followed
by a trio of parts and robert rodriguez
projects including machete kills while
shooting blair witch in vancouver she
made a singing tape that led to her
playing one of emma stone's roommates in
la la land her credits also include
ridley scott's alien covenant tv's
graves and under the silver lake next on
her dance card is joining jennifer lopez
and josh demelle for shotgun wedding
peter is james's skeptical childhood
friend in the 3rd blair witch film and
is played by tuscaloosa native brandon
scott scott told his hometown newspaper
that 2016's blair witch is more of an
homage to the first one but it takes the
story to the nth degree even though it
leaves a lot of easter eggs and open
questions a graduate of new york
university's tisch school of the arts in
2004 scott has racked up north of 70
credits since leaving school his voice
was heard in disney's wreck-it ralph in
the boss baby tv series and he's been
seen in everything from showtime's
gorilla to this is us to dead to me in
goliath in a blair witch alumni pairing
scott played lucky and joshua leonard's
2018 directed feature dark was the
knight
corbin reed was definitely scared when
reading the script for blair witch for
which she was cast as ashley the poor
girl gets a nasty infection on her foot
during the journey which is one of the
last things you'd want in the deep dark
woods in real life reed was able to
escape the forest and nab 13 episode
stints on both how to get away with
murder and valor in 2019 she wrote
directed and executive produced the
short film blind site and she is
currently making waves starring on the
star series run the world the minnesotan
is an avid long-distance runner a lover
of puppies and interior design her dream
role is to play whitney houston
in the third blair witch film locals
lane and talia are conspiracy theorists
who found lost footage of heather
donahue taped to a tree in the woods
their find sets the plot in motion with
the two acting as guides for james and
his friends valerie curry who played
talia never saw the original when she
was younger telling vogue i was
terrified of e.t as a small child i had
a low threshold for fear curry's early
acting career began with six episodes of
veronica mars but she took a break soon
after to see if another vocation would
stick and it didn't she returned to the
craft in 2011 with parts on csi new york
psych the twilight saga breaking dawn
part 2 and even appearing in blink 182's
music video for the song after midnight
her residency on the show the following
not only earned her steady paycheck but
it was also where she met her future
husband actor sam underwood the two have
since acted together in a pair of short
films at the edinburgh fringe festival
and even perform music together live
other notable works include playing cara
on the video game detroit become human
and appearing in the tick tv series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]